und wir blicken auf den fall der uns auf
fühlt wie kein zweiter der fall weil ihn
die woche hat damit begonnen mit der
nachricht dass der mutmaßliche mörder
von eileen
polizeibekannt ist mehr noch dass ihr
mutmaßliche mörder ein verurteilter
sexualstraftäter ist einer dem man
wieder rausgelassen hat aus der
psychiatrie nach zehn jahren am ende
dieser woche nach langen recherchen
unserer reporter ist klar dieser fall
aline der ist auch das dramatische
versagen der behörden
eileen 14 jahre jung brutal ermordet sie
könnte noch leben wenn polizei und
justiz konsequent gehandelt hätten immer
mehr unglaubliche details kommen jetzt
ans licht immer wieder fiel alliance
mörder dadurch auf dass er sich an
kinder und junge mädchen heran machte
niemand stoppte ihn bis es zu spät war
jan heiko stock vor dem mord an eileen
ein weiteres opfer eine 17 jährige das
mädchen und die schule alarmieren die
polizei doch nichts geschieht und die
schande geht weiter jan heiko p der mann
der zehn jahre wegen versuchter
vergewaltigung einer elfjährigen im
maßregelvollzug saß legt beschwerde
wegen seiner dauerhaften überwachung ein
und unfassbar das landgericht limburg
gibt ihm recht wie kann das sein bild
fragt den richter und autor thorsten
schleif war das beenden der
führungsaufsicht wirklich juristisch
notwendig warum soll bei einem
verurteilten
sexualstraftäter der versucht hat ein
kind zu vergewaltigen und erneut
straffällig geworden ist eine
unbefristete führungsaufsicht
unverhältnismäßig sein das ist unfug am
25 januar endet die frist zu überwachen
damit laufen alle maßnahmen wie die
führungsaufsicht aus bei einer solchen
tat sollte die unbefristete
führungsaufsicht bereits bei der ersten
verurteilung angeordnet werden hier ist
eine gesetzesänderung dringend
erforderlich ist darf doch nicht sein
dass ein pädophiler sexualstraftäter
irgendwann aus der überwachung fällt und
was tut die polizei sie führt beim
späteren mörder nur eine einzige
gefährde ansprache durch eindeutig zu
wenig meint richter torsten schlaf es
wäre auch zulässig gewesen mehrere
gefährderansprachen durchzuführen um zu
zeigen wir haben dich im blick ich kenne
auch polizeibeamten die das gemacht
haben das verheerende fazit wenn gericht
staatsanwaltschaft und polizei ihre
möglichkeiten besser ausgeschöpft und
gehandelt hätten dann könnte er ihn
heute noch leben
[Musik]